[Music]
McDonagh gives us a rare glimpse into
her private world the Material Girl is
opening up to People magazine about her
emotional journey adopting her for
Malawi born children her two eleven year
olds David and mercy and five year old
twins ester and Stella the 59 year old
singer tells the mag she's had some
pretty dark moments throughout the
process but maintains quote I'm a
survivor
[Music]
first came David who Maj felt an instant
connection with after meeting him as a
sickly baby but when she brought him
home to London in 2008 she tells the mag
every newspaper said I kidnapped him
adding quote that was a real low point
for me I would cry myself to sleep
[Music]
next came mercy this adoption was tough
because the 59 year old singer had
recently divorced Guy Ritchie as a
result Malawi and officials told her she
was not capable of raising a child she
won that battle in 2009 and then brought
home two more her orphan twins
this February Madonna calls the process
rigorous and says she certainly didn't
get any kind of special treatment
[Music]
now seven months later it's as if little
esther and stella has been here all
along but they still have no clue who
their famous mama is the Queen of Pop
says that's a good thing I'm just their
mother
[Music]
you